let's jump to an even more depressing
story we got this from the post
millennial breaking Moody's Slash's
outlook for U.S banking system to
negative due to rapidly deteriorating
operating environment Moody's lowered
its outlook on the American banking
banking system from stable to negative
the move comes just days after Silicon
Valley Bank the 16th largest in the
nation collapsed alongside a number of
smaller financial institutions quote we
have changed our okay we get it they say
it over and over again we've changed our
state our negative from stable to
negative according to CNBC the downgrade
could impact credit ratings and thus
raise the cost of borrowing for
financial institutions oh boy that's
going to make everything a whole lot
worse so this morning when uh trading
opens up all the banking stocks spiked
and skyrocketed some jumped something
like 90 point swings it made a lot of
money if you invested in them on the dip
but it was so volatile that a bunch of
trading halts were implemented because
the upswing was also extreme and crazy
so that just screams volatility
I gotta Wonder
Where Do We Go From Here some people
have predicted that
you know in 2008 it was March we saw the
first hits then by September it was
total collapse we're looking at the same
thing here or going to be different well
the question is trust the only reason
that the dollar is the fiat currency of
the world and and we have been on top as
long as we have and we can have 30
trillion dollars in debt is because
people believe that the United States is
Unbreakable
well it doesn't look unbreakable now and
that's the problem you know that's
that's been the issue you look at why
crypto is is being adapted but not not
fast enough it's because how many people
trust that everybody because if
everybody in that crypto game doesn't
trust each other it falls apart well
we've been so trusted that people
thought the US is just always going to
be there always going to be growing
always going to be fine and the second
that trust is Pierce everything the
crypto Bros have been saying about why
fiat currency is garbage becomes true
because it is a Ponzi scheme we owe more
money than we'll ever make the only
chance we have is to screw the Chinese
and not pay them back well there's
there's no such thing as paying down the
debt no we can't people understand that
a large portion of the national that's
owed to itself to its own its own people
and that's just it's always going to
increase because the system itself is a
Ponzi scheme where basically we borrow
from ourselves in the future over and
over and over again forever it works
when you have all the guns that's why
the US government doesn't like it when
you know regular people start Ponzi
schemes well and now the Chinese are
looking at they've wanted to flip the
the currency to their own for a long
time it's happening I think Saudi Arabia
is doing it and look at what they did
they just China is pushing us aside as
the is the world's only superpower and
it's happening because we look like
punks you know we've always been
vulnerable but we look strong Trump
crazy as he was nobody wanted to mess
with him nobody wanted to to take the
consequences of what he would do
nobody's scared of Biden you know the
Iran the Iranians and the Saudis just
signed a deal brokered by the Chinese
yeah so our major Global enemy Brokers a
deal between the largest state sponsor
of terrorism and a former Ally of ours
three years after we were making deals
in the Middle East to bring Gulf Arab
states and Israel together we have lost
our place what's the what's the answer
more International War more conflict
more intervention that seems to be where
the Biden Administration wants to go
they seem to be doing everything they
can to push us into World War III I
don't know if it's because they think
it'll help the defense stocks or if they
just don't know how to control it
because they want a unipolar world where
the U.S controls the reserve currency
and if we lose that unipolar position it
becomes multi-polar with China as it is
then the US dollar becomes worthless and
the U.S manufactures nothing so we
become a poor Nation overnight and and
the Chinese are globalists just not the
way that we talk about globalism they're
globalist as in they want to control the
globe and if we if we lose to them and
right now they're they're also they're
going to broker a deal between the
Russians and the ukrainians I predict in
the next three to six months they're
going to be the ones who make that deal
not us because Biden and his crew can't
stop pushing all right they want that
war because that's what makes them feel
strong that's what they're doing like
you said to maintain our position and
they're incompetent at it that's the
problem if the U.S falls from the uh
holder of the reserve currency then the
watch becomes the reserve currency and
then it's China and then this is screwed
I mean so it it really does feel in a
lot of ways like
I I think Donald Trump understood this
and his view of the world was the U.S
will not be able to maintain this
position China is growing too fast we
need to shore up our borders we need to
bring back manufacturing build up our
economy and get ready otherwise it'll be
a hard fall and the establishment unit
party deep State said no we just need to
blow up more people and just keep
dropping bombs until they learn they
can't screw with us and the dollar is
the reserve currency I think trouble's
right they can't they can't stop China's
growth no well I don't know China may
stop its own growth they're they're a
bit of a potemkin economy you know
they've got a lot of stuff behind the
scenes that is ugly and I think they are
they're not in a position to capitalize
except they're authoritarian structure
allows them to rapidly shift priorities
steal any resource they want on a
moment's notice it's much more difficult
for the us but the U.S still does do it
uh it's not like the will of the people
really matters to the US government for
the most part well and the other thing
that has been happening between the UNA
party and the and the globalists you
know the world economic Forum crew is
weakening the United States they want to
weaken it enough to allow a global
counterpart to push up against the
Chinese they think they can do it if the
U.S is weak enough and somehow they
spread that power across all of the
component parts of like the G20 then
you've got a global organization that
can take on the Chinese and is better
than it and the problem is the Chinese
could win before that happens
coalesce around that outside of all that
our banks are falling apart which is not
good yeah all right you want a good
prediction so 100 years ago there was a
Great Depression what started it well
stocks crashed there were runs on banks
right right so everything was really bad
then there was possibility of a World
War coming right after that wasn't there
don't we have just after World War one
yeah so we'd finished one the war to end
all wars and then all of a sudden we
have a depression and then oh we need
another world war right so now we've got
a World War Brewing so I'm saying all we
got to do is ride that's it too how
about pandemic we didn't have that back
then but you had the Spanish flu and
other things so you got and all the same
things that took everybody down but you
know what here's what you got to
remember the greatest period of
prosperity was right after second world
war so all we got to do is write out the
next 20 years and we'll be fine 25 or so
and then it'll be a few years after that
one of the things that helped to bolster
the US economy was the complete
destruction of the of the manufacturing
bases in the countries that were at War
right Japan was was wiped out and much
of Europe was wiped out so if you needed
something made it was American well
here's the thing maybe we need to bait
China and Russia the problem is China
and Russia are allies now you got the
dragon bear Alliance and so the the odds
of them getting into a fight and
destroying their manufacturing
capability is Slim so we're not going to
get that bonus we need to uh take
Trump's advice we need to protect our
borders we need to start manufacturing
we need to start becoming more
self-sufficient because I think the long
fall is coming imagine what would what
it would be like if Donald Trump was
President for the past two years
you would have more manufacturing you'd
have a stronger U.S economy you'd have
lower inflation you'd have less war
you'd have no war in Ukraine I mean
it just sounds really nice doesn't it it
I I think that's probably reasonable to
to assume that there wouldn't be a war
in Ukraine
um I'm not so sure about the other stuff
because Donald Trump was spending was
printing money just as fast as Biden was
we'd had a lot of the same issues maybe
we get out of it pardon me we didn't
the the but the pandemic is a weird
scenario yeah that goes from 2020 into
2021 I'm not going to blame either Biden
or Trump for the weirdness but I can say
the moment Biden gets into office and
signs all these executive orders
inflation just shoots straight up and
wages go straight down
I I really don't think Donald Trump
secretly planned a policy to to execute
the moment or within like three weeks of
Biden becoming president no I mean I
just signed a bunch of executive orders
and nuked everything there's a there's
there is an amount of Truth to that the
the uh executive orders that Biden
signed when he first got into office
well there's a lot of regulations that
he he reinstated and stuff but still the
the the main factors that led to the
inflation and stuff I mean Donald Trump
was talking about doing in uh doing more
stimulus uh at the end of his at the end
of his
at the end of his presidency and stuff
so I don't see a significant difference
economically I think that we're probably
in the same place whether it be Biden or
Trump but as for international stuff
like foreign relations and stuff I think
the world the US was better well the
world was better off with Donald Trump
than with with uh than with Biden I
think that's pretty clear I don't think
we're I don't think we see a war in
Ukraine without Donald Trump not a
chance and we didn't see any of the
tyrants acting up you know and all of a
sudden Biden's in and everybody knows
they can roll over his team they show us
oh let's do Afghanistan
swimmingly everybody knew that Donald
Trump's incentive was I want America to
be a nice place for Americans I don't
care about you and they said okay so
Russia's like well I'm not gonna need to
invade if if the U.S isn't pushing for
NATO expansion anymore and then with the
way they frame it in the corporate press
here is Donald Trump was doing Putin's
bidding why because his bidding was he
didn't want a NATO country bordering
like every every border country to be a
NATO country that was one of those great
missed opportunities was we could have
made a frenemy out of Russia Russia
because they needed it they didn't have
China yet now we screwed that up okay we
made an enemy out of what was an enemy
let's be clear Putin was always going to
be an enemy but you can make deals with
enemies now he's making a deal with our
actual enemy who's actually capable of
taking us on on the global stage and
we're on the sidelines you know it's
horrifying yeah sometimes I feel like
the American Media treats Russia so
strangely like they didn't want an
expansion of a Alliance that would
attack them against their back door and
some for some reason we presented as
like that's crazy can you believe that
and they didn't want us to do that like
I I feel like the pressure to keep
Russia as our number one enemy which of
course like there are conflicts but like
personally I feel like we have more to
lose to China right now 100 and instead
we get to spend how much money on
Ukraine because who is a stand-in for
Trump for a lot of these people a lot of
the people in the U.S who are pushing so
hard are using Putin as their Trump
punching bag in the same way he said oh
you know it's Trump is doing Putin's
bidding no what's actually going on was
Trump was trying to neutralize the one
thing Trump was good at is he was a
Savvy negotiator you didn't want to be
across the table in a boardroom from
Donald Trump because he was going to eat
your lunch and he didn't care how he did
it he made Putin nervous he made Kim
Jong-un nervous he made the Chinese
nervous he hit him with tariffs you know
he kept everybody off balance now
everybody knows they can roll Biden and
they're all rolling up on us thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time